жадібних sony іванова tasty савченко за у
сіма пунктів і званого чий постанови в
донецький суд ростовської області
r us правій нозі та савченко самобранка
вердикт суду слухала spoke in a pas
Міхав ася і на те співала судді за
спин адвокатів
у Європі ви руку відразу прокоментував
та голова німецької української
парламентської групи уганда стасик
аргілак фільму ви служб одягання що на
за баром надя савченко ваш досвід знайти на
свободі відскок методами і марина росія
з пробуючи ви краси надій савченко в
кістки важливо lead-ins купе годину рис на
монетних переговорів ми рекомендуємо
росії швидкого ви вирішите проблему
дипломатичним шляхом наприклад а у
мене ти савченко на нижчих за соджин
яків андреїв назвати учениця фракції
зелених у європарламенті ребекка хармс
за кликала євросоюз до класу ти у всіх
зус іль до ланки не української льотчиці
пройдусь ним а мсп одягається на візит
міністра за кордон справної машини до
Москви вже в середу та філіровку
навіть добрий що франк-вальтер штайнмайєр
що до початку свого візиту до Москви
заявивши що у днів з тим пробурив стане
справа надій савченко
думаю вентру бути санвузол його для того
щоб савченко наріжте змогла поїхати і
додому
липовим європа на упокоритеся з
результатом цього ж нервового процесу
поінтів ну що в самій Москві будуть
просить і за звір не надя і савченко
експерти розходяться в оцінках
найму повернеш і зняття європейських
санкцій а за енче вчинку ось ночі
сусіду виноси йому руку в європарламенті
взяла азарус рубку сантино у списку
савченко і до нього ж стати дієго побачити
людей євросоюзу на руки російського в
суду